we're back now with a hard look at what
is an American disgrace the treatment of
immigrant children at the border this
week officials moved hundreds of
children out of one of the worst
detention facilities after reports of
deplorable conditions at a contentious
court hearing judges took a government
larger task for the conditions there
it's within everybody's common
understanding that you know if you don't
have a toothbrush if you don't have soap
if you don't have a blanket it's not
safe and sanitary well wouldn't
everybody agree to that do you agree to
that well I think it's I think those are
there's fair reason to find that those
things may be part of see maybe are a
part what do you say maybe we're joined
tonight by one of the few reporters
who's been on the front lines since the
beginning John Carlos Frey John thanks
for joining us your new book on the
subject sand and blood is just out what
do you make of what's going on with the
children at the border
I have report after report after report
of children being mistreated by Customs
and Border Protection over the past
couple of decades you and I have even
reported together about things that
happen on the border I'm actually glad
that this is coming to the forefront but
this is actually US policy we're
supposed to make this journey and
incarceration about as bad as you can
possibly imagine this is this is part of
what Donald Trump is basically using
legally in other words to make it to
discourage families from making the move
towards the u.s. is that the idea make
it so painful yes the policy is known as
a deterrence policy we're never going to
be able to keep everybody from coming
we're never gonna be able to seal off
the border and keep migrants from coming
so let's shake them up a little bit
let's make them cross the deserts or the
mountains if we catch them and we
incarcerate them let's not give them a
cushy bed let's not give them good food
let's not even let them sleep let's
leave the lights on no toothpaste no
toothbrush no no mattresses the way the
children are being treated is part of US
government policy I think this has all
come to a head this week with some of
the
moving pictures of children the young
father who died along with his daughter
drowned trying to cross the Rio Grande
do you see opportunity for change here
now because of a national outrage it
seems like that's the only thing that
ever moves the needle if if the
citizenry is aware of what's going on
this is policy that has gone on under
under a cloak of secrecy for for a long
time so I'm hopeful that the the fact
that this now is in the light and
exactly what happens that maybe at least
the administration made you your new
book deals with the people who are
actually making money from all this how
can that be
well you know we just saw an
appropriations bill that the House
passed and it looks like the Senate
passed as well for four point plus
billion dollars for aid who's going to
implement that aid those are defense
contractors that's four billion dollars
for the most part put into private
enterprises hands to feed the children
to to provide sanitary conditions this
is all a system of private contractors
that basically manage the border and
manage the way people are detained we
detain about 50,000 people in detention
facilities and 75% of those detention
facilities are privately run and
privately managed so their discomfort
means big money for someone it's
estimated that we when we started to see
children at the border at the beginning
of last year that defense contractor
swooped in and made about a billion
dollars instituting these these places
where they're being held 1 billion
dollars to hold children John some of
your reporting that's been on this
program has to deal with the fact that
that area of Central America from which
many of the people are coming is
suffering from a famine with conditions
that are really responsible that are
drying up the land sort of climate
change we're seeing some of the early
results the World Food Program which is
a subsidiary of the United Nations in
February this year has declared 2.1
million people as being food insecure
that is the step before all-out famine
and that's as you say is a direct result
of people losing their crops the is
drying out due to climate Lee
I'd throw out now 2.1 million people who
can't feed themselves we're starting to
see them at the border and you think
that's driving them towards the u.s. the
fact that they can't feed themselves
they don't have jobs well this is one of
the sending factors by Gration is
complicated if you can't feed your
family if you can't find a job if you're
afraid for your life because of the
violence all of those things piled on
may make someone make the decision to
move northward and that's what we're
seeing I was in the caravans at the end
of last year that were heading to the
us-mexico border and many of the people
that I spoke to were farmers who could
no longer farmed land because the rains
just weren't coming and I talked to
several people who were living on one
tortilla a day that's about as much as
they could muster president Trump has
repeatedly said this is the
responsibility and the fault frankly of
the Obama administration is there
anything to that I don't I don't even
understand what that statement means
he's been president for two years the
executive branch is responsible for
implementing immigration policy
I think Obama's been out of office for a
while so either he's not taking
responsibility or trying to find blame
but it's his job now if Obama screwed
things up that was a couple of years ago
it's his job now his administration is
responsible for what we're seeing help
our viewers understand the whole issue
of asylum us grants asylum were being
flooded with people seeking asylum we
have laws on the books that actually
allow people to come to the border and
say I'm being persecuted I'm a victim of
violence I am afraid for my life I'd
like to come and seek refuge in the
United States we let them in and we
allow them to go through a court process
it's the courts who decide whether or
not their claims are legitimate and if
the court decides that they're not they
will be deported 90% of the cases are
usually not found to be credible so most
of the people are returned but they are
given the opportunity to make their
claim so the fact that the president is
keeping people from making a claim of
asylum is basically in violation of our
own laws the the picture that we're all
seeing this horrible picture of the man
with his child drown in the Rio Grande
is said by his wife to have tried to
make a claim of asylum but he was denied
so he tried to swim the river so I think
that there is blood on the hands of the
administration by not allowing these
individuals to make the legal claims and
in some cases that's why they're coming
to the border blood on their hands you
really mean that yeah I really do you
know I mean if we're not giving Children
and Families the opportunity to make a
claim of asylum which we by law are
supposed to and people are dying as a
result who's responsible
if migrants are dying by the thousands
in the deserts due to our policies are
we not responsible the only the only
individuals are the only group who can
alleviate the suffering is the federal
government and if they're not doing that
I think that we have to take a look at
the fact that our policies are causing
great harm yeah I I'm not really being
hyperbolic here and as a journalist I'm
very careful about the words that I
choose but I'm not sure that people
would be dying in mass as they are or
being treated in such inhumane
conditions if it wasn't for the way
we're implementing policy John Carlos
Frey thank you so much for joining us as
always thank you Brian